Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I want to talk about mistakes.
We all make mistakes.
Some people are upset
when they make mistakes.
I'm not, and I want to go into some
detail on how we can take advantage
of this, the mistakes that we make to
do better in our language learning.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe.
You can click on the bell
to get notifications.
And by all means join me at
LingQ where I learn languages.
So, you know, we can not understand when
things are said, or we can not understand
when we read, because we didn't quite
hear, hear it properly or we've forgotten
the word, or we don't know the word.
So there are all kinds of ways
that we can simply not understand,
but that's not a mistake.
There's no anxiety there.
There's only anxiety if you don't
understand when you're in a conversation.
In other words, somebody says something
to you and you don't understand what
they're saying so that you can reply.
You can't say anything.
There there's anxiety.
But if you are engaged in input
activities, such as listening and
reading, certainly I can tolerate a lot
of vagueness, ambiguity, misunderstanding.
It really doesn't bother me because
I know that through continuing
my input activities, I will
gradually see things more clearly,
understand things more clearly.
There's no great pressure on me.
However, as soon as you start speaking
with someone, things change, as I said,
if you don't understand what they're
saying, that's quite intimidating.
In fact, to me, that's the most
intimidating thing when I don't
understand what people are saying,
I can't even attempt to reply.
However, there's also the problem when
you say something and you say it wrong,
you use the wrong word, you use the wrong
tense, you use the wrong form of the verb
or the noun, whatever it might be or, or
the structure, the phrasing is incorrect.
And so your conscious...
Or you might pronounce poorly and you're
conscious of the difficulty that you have.
Uh, sometimes you can watch a video or
listen to an audio of yourself and you
will notice mistakes that you made,
that maybe you weren't aware of while
you were engaged in the conversation.
And that's often very useful because
then you can really then zoom in on those
areas and try to improve or, you know,
pay attention to them when you next come
across them and in listening and reading.
But, um, It is a bit unsettling.
There's a fear.
People don't want to make mistakes.
Um, when we study of school, we
make mistakes on our little test.
And so we get marked down for them.
And so we, we sort of develop this
habit, this sense that mistakes are bad.
Uh, if I get a test at school
and I go 10 out of 10, I'm good.
If I go five out of 10, I'm bad.
But the reality is that he's in my
experiences that I can get something right
one time and wrong the next time, wrong
the first time and right the next time.
Uh, it depends what the
brain is doing at the moment.
Sometimes it remembers it
correctly and sometimes it doesn't.
And so I think it's not a good
thing to train ourselves, to
think of mistakes as bad things.
To me, a mistake is an
opportunity to improve.
You make a mistake very often you're
aware that you made a mistake.
You're either aware that, uh, you might
be aware of what the correct usage was.
Or you might simply not be
sure what the correct usage is.
And so you are bothered by that, that
being bothered by mistakes, potential
or actual mistakes, it drives that
curiosity, that desire to focus in
on that structure, that use of words
or whatever, and to get better at it.
And so to that extent, mistakes
are a sign that we are pushing
ourselves outside of our comfort zone.
Uh, it's an opportunity to become aware of
the gaps we have in what we have learned.
It's a, it's a very positive thing in
the process of learning a language.
That's why I'm not a fan of tests.
Uh, there are people who can score
well on tests who can get certain
fine points of grammar correctly,
but cannot communicate properly,
don't understand very well.
I think if you throw yourself into the
idea of communicating for the sake of
communicating and gradually building
up your comprehension, building up your
vocabulary, building up your ability to
marshal the words, uh, produce the words
in the correct sort of usage pattern.
All of which the brain will gradually do.
The brain will not be able
to remember a specific rule.
Uh, if you try to force it to
remember the, you know, the specific
usage patterns, but the brain
will gradually get more and more
used to these patterns, possibly
reminded by a grammatic, uh, grammar
explanation, and very often reminded
by the fact that you got it wrong.
And so the, the fact that you got
it wrong triggers this desire to
get closer to what that usage is.
Now, there are people who continue to make
the same mistakes over and over again.
And I think that's a lack of, of
attentiveness to the language.
Uh, you have to want to notice
what's happening in the language.
So I definitely do recommend recording,
say a conversation or doing a video
even, in a foreign language and then
listening to it and see, seeing if
you can pick out your own mistakes.
And even if you pick them out
and you look up the rule or you
pay attention to it, that doesn't
mean you're going to get it right.
The next time there is
no immediate correction.
Teachers may think that they
can correct you and that
therefore you'll get it right.
That has never been my experience.
When I taught English, say, as a
tutor at LingQ, I could correct
the person three, four times.
They would still make the same mistake.
When I go through my, uh, tutors
reports at lingQ I'll see that I get
the same correction from them, the
same phrase or word that I used wrong.
I use it wrong week after week,
but eventually I get it right.
So it doesn't bother me that because my
whole, the whole learning process is a
continuing, a continuum of knowing less,
understanding less, making more mistakes
and gradually understanding or having
more words and making fewer mistakes.
So at a given point in time,
that I'm making a lot of mistakes
that's an indication that I'm learning.
You know, if I were to limit myself to
a very narrow range of words and only
ever talk about the weather or things
that I'm comfortable talking about,
where I have got a sort of a routine
that I know is more or less correct.
That's not learning the language.
It's only when I push myself into,
you know, ever, you know, broader,
uh, range of subject matter,
and try to express my views on
those things that I'm learning.
And of course, inevitably, if I do
that, I'm going to make more mistakes.
So mistakes are valuable.
Mistakes are an indication that you're
pushing yourself beyond the comfort
of a limited range of subject matter.
If you're paying attention to what you're
saying, paying attention to what the
native speaker is saying, then you are
able to then focus in on these areas.
When you are listening and reading
and all of this is part of the
gradual process of improving yourself.
And as I have said, often in
quoting Manfred Spitzer, the brain
cannot do otherwise than learn.
If you expose the brain to the patterns
of the language, you expose the brain
to try to say things and getting them
wrong, and then reminding yourself
of what the correct usage was,
and you keep, keep on doing these
things, the brain will gradually develop.
Patterns for using the language that are
more and more correct, more and more,
uh, based on the standard usage of, of
what you've been listening to and what
you've been hearing people say, but that
process of learning is a slow process.
It's not because you are taught something
that you're going to get it right.
So we need to have patience.
We need to be indulgent with ourselves.
We need to recognize mistakes for what
they are, valuable mind milestones
as we progress in our language.
So there you have it.
That's my take on mistakes and, um,
I'll leave you with a couple of videos
that might reinforce this message.
Thanks for listening.
Bye.
For now.